voici la liste le l'inventaire du
premier donc de la pharmacie bessèges
emplois de commerciaux dans ses cartons
du matériel médical habituellement
destinés au bloc opératoire des dons
récoltés par cette association près de
perpignan pour être envoyés en urgence
en ukraine donc c'est tout ce qui est
pansements seringues cathéters matériel
de perfusion
tout le matériel pour soigner les
premiers blessés qui vont arriver dans
les hôpitaux d'ukraine
l'association a lancé un appel aux dons
sur sa page facebook pour récolter un
maximum de matériel mais aussi des
financements cet appel aux dons c'est
pour nous aider c'est pour nous aider
pour du matériel pour acheminer notre
matériel 1 et pour diverses choses
ça coûte entre 3 et 4000 euros donc
c'est vrai que c'est une somme quand
même qui est assez conséquente depuis
hier le téléphone de jeanine l'escaut
franco-ukrainienne n'arrête pas de
sonner à l'autre bout du fil de la
famille des amis et de l'inquiétude là
bas on attend l'arrivée des colis avec
impatience ça va
commencer en tout cas
pas urgent tout de suite
un point de collecte a été ouvert à la
mairie du village et l'initiative
trouvent écho auprès des habitants
si on peut aider à oui biensur fait
plaisir trouve que c'est bien au
contraire il faut aider il faudrait
toujours aider les gens qui en ont
besoin donc bonne initiative
l'association espère faire partir un
premier camion d'aidé humanitaire le
plus rapidement possible pour aider
leurs proches même à plus de 2500
kilomètres de là